hello
my name is lily and me and my friends
come from bulgaria
to visit the allianza and we are huge
fans of bayern munich
come on friends
this is our ticket look how many tickets
okay
all in all we have a capacity of 71 000
spectators
i count from three to one and then i
want to hear a loud gold we have to be
louder than all the other guys
ready three two one
our guide is the best
okay we are going to the dressing
room yes yeah so here we have it the
dressing room of probably the best team
in the world right now
i would really like to see
thomas mueller undressing here
the best was when we get out and feeling
like a
soccer player and a big star
it is raining now but we are still
looking for somewhere to stop and to eat
because we are very hungry
it's really interesting that we see
ukrainian dancers in the
munich in bavaria
fantastic
at 11 o'clock at 12 o'clock and at 5
00 pm the figures are starting to move
it's five o'clock and they're still not
moving
it's interesting
we have a great time here and now we are
very very tired so
bye bye